So now you are able to solve such a differential equation with the help of the exponential function.
We can easily say now that N of T equals its initial value times E to the minus T divided by 20 seconds.
Such an equation can, for instance, be used to model radioactive decay.
N of T would be the number of atoms that have not yet decayed at time T.
And this derivative, the rate of change, tells you the current speed of decay, which is the current number divided by 20
per second. You would expect 1/20th of the current number of atoms to decay within the next second.
This is not entirely true because that number, of course, is not constant during that second.
And there's another caveat. This is a number, a natural number. So keep in mind that this, again, as everything,
is just a model; it's not reality.
One important thing to learn about such a process is the mean lifetime of a particle.
If you look at one single particle, how long does it take, on average, for it to decay?
If you look at, say, a billion particles, and form the average of their lifetimes.
And now we're going to figure out a way to compute the lifetime from this differential equation.